- [Voiceover] The party was crazy.
- [Voiceover] Did you have fun?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, yeah.
- [Voiceover] I'm starving!
- [Voiceover] Let's go here.
- [Voiceover] They have really
good burritos. Want one?
- Burrito sounds good, yeah.
- [Voiceover] I got you. You have a menu?
Western one, two of those. K? Thanks.
Teo, I got, uh...
(smooth house music)
(people talking)
- I'm so sorry. He's just,
he's just really drunk.
- Yeah, he's my buddy.
- I apologize.
(smooth house music)
♫ You keep on ca--
- Hey. Pretty Lady.
- [Friend] Teo.
(laughs)
♫ --lling me. Up.
♫ You keep on calling.
(lip smack)
(smooth house music)
- [Friend] Stop. You're
gonna hurt yourself, man.
- (slips) Ow!
- [Friend] Are you okay?
(smooth house music)
I'm so sorry. Here.
- You need to leave.
- [Friend] Teo, stop.
No, we're gonna get an Uber.
- [Worker] I've been holdin
this broom for a long time.
- [Friend] The Uber's gonna
come in like five minutes.
- [Worker] He's like really sober.
- [Friend] He's not sober, he can't drive.
- [Woman] You know what?
Sure, why not?
(smooth house music)
- [Teo] Bye, Miles.
- How're you getting home?
Crazy, huh?
- Sometimes.
(wiping whoosh)
(sign creaks)
- You need help?
- Look, man, can you just go?
- Yeah, I'll go.